All right, we've been talking about all different types of components within a system.
And now we're going to teach my my daughter here.
And now we're going to teach my my daughter here about storage within a system.
We're going to talk about the two primary types of storage within a system, primary storage
and secondary storage.
So this is where we keep the bits in our computer system.
Later in life, this is where you'll keep your like Instagram photos or whatever the
kids are doing that when you're growing up, okay?
So what does primary storage mean?
Primary storage means it's volatile memory, whereas secondary storage is often referred
to as non-volatile memory.
So what's that word volatile mean?
Well, soon you'll learn that volatile means it's something that can sort of disappear
at regular temperatures.
And that's a really good way of thinking about primary storage or volatile memory.
If the power gets pulled, any of that data in volatile memory disappears.
It's gone.
Whereas in non-volatile memory, the data remains even when the system is powered down.
So let's look at some examples of both primary and secondary storage and we'll start with
primary storage.
So some really good examples of primary storage are things like my daughter's trying to
eat my finger here, she's teething.
So examples of primary storage are cash, registers, RAM.
And all of these are very, very high speed forms of storage.
So what do we primarily use volatile memory for?
We use primary or volatile memory for data that's actively being used by the system,
for programs that have been loaded that are in memory, that the CPU is currently processing.
And what we want this primary storage for is for the data that needs to be accessed very,
very quickly.
And so cash, registers, this is actually data or this is actually storage built into
the processor itself.
Whereas RAM, RAM, access memory is actually memory modules built into the system.
But it's quite fast.
So what are the pros and cons of primary storage?
Well, as we talked about, primary storage, very, very fast, but it is volatile.
Like you're getting here.
So what about secondary storage?
It's kind of the inverse.
Examples of secondary storage are things like magnetic hard drives, optical media drives,
tapes, solid state drives.
These are all examples of secondary storage.
They're not nearly as fast, but they can store a lot more data.
A lot more pictures of you, cutie.
So what do we primarily use secondary storage for?
We use secondary storage for storing the data and the program code when it's not being
used.
So pictures, things like that, data from programs, movies, they're stored in our secondary
storage.
Now, let's talk about one other concept and it's known as virtual memory.
And to explain virtual memory, we have to understand a little bit how a computer system
actually works.
So you've probably noticed when you double click on an icon like Word, it actually takes
a little bit of time for that program to load.
And in fact, there's often what we call a load screen.
So what is a load screen?
A load screen is where the program is telling you it's actually taking data from secondary
storage, from slower hard drives, and it's moving it into RAM, into memory, much higher
speed storage.
And the reason you want this to occur is that the processor works so incredibly quickly.
It's always going through calculations.
We've had to wait for a very long time for some data that's requested to come back from
say secondary storage.
It would really significantly slow the computer system down.
So when we load a program, what we're actually doing is transferring data from secondary
storage, the hard drive, into primary storage, RAM, random access memory.
Can you say that out loud?
Probably not yet.
So there's a problem though with this.
If you've got too many programs running, if you've loaded too many programs, you're
going to run out of this primary storage known as RAM.
And you've probably heard numbers relate to your computer systems.
It's not uncommon that a computer will have, say, four or eight gigabytes of RAM, and
you'll have like, terabytes of storage.
So RAM is really, really small, relatively, to the secondary storage.
And so the problem we had is if we've loaded too many programs into RAM, we start to run
out of RAM.
And a computer system, if it were to run out of memory entirely, the system would crash.
And in fact, we used to see this a lot.
So there used to be something called the blue screen of death.
Hopefully, you'll never have to see that in your life.
But in Windows, if you had too many things loaded and the system ran out of RAM, ran out
of this primary storage, you'd actually get a blue screen, the system would crash.
So a way that we found, the industry is found to actually deal with this problem is to use
what is known as virtual memory.
And this is the concept, drooly face, where we move some data out of RAM back to the hard
drive.
And we temporarily store it on the hard drive until it's neat again.
And then we can move it again back from the hard drive, woo, we were falling, back into
primary storage.
And that's the concept of virtual memory.
It's simply this idea that some data that's not being used very often is moved out of
RAM onto the hard drive.
And then when it's needed again, back into memory.
With the overall effect, it definitely slows down the system.
But the system keeps running, so that's virtual memory.